i'd done as much practically as i could
the sets were elaborate the fights
vicious and the horses were real but
there was a whole lot more than this
that went into the making of the harder
they fall most of what we see in the
movie was fully created on the scene
these production values were high the
name of the train cab is the chadwick
boseman homage regina king facing off
against a train bravely was all real we
don't know whose performance is better
kings or her horses
the explosions yep they made that happen
only had to enhance a couple of ways
with the burning money all the street
lights in redwood were practical as well
and provided the perfect ambiance every
start in this film is me jonathan majors
went into hardcore cowboy mode right off
the bat early on i said i asked i said i
want to do all the stunts all of them
horses guns
shoot out all of it hand-to-hand all of
it performing all of his own stunts was
key for majors getting into the mindset
of his character so he learned how to
ride and work with a horse well enough
just like any real cowboy would majors
put in a lot of hours working with his
horse co-star the bonanza creek ranch
making sure they'd be ready for their
time on camera who here can drive a
train
hey everybody buddy idris alba loved
making this film there's no doubt about
it but he would have preferred to work
with an animal that he wasn't allergic
to i mean i had to learn we both had to
learn to ride horses but i'm allergic to
horses okay elba being allergic to the
horse he did multiple scenes with wasn't
great but these animals were so
intuitive and the actors still managed
to connect and perform well with the
film horses
even if he was a bit wheezy
the team literally had to take breaks
every now and then so elba could take a
breather away from the stallions
everyone on this set was committing but
sometimes it went a little bit too far
idris elba and dion cole actually wound
up making contact when they hit each
other at times we was just so passionate
that we ended up connecting a few times
and you can see it on our eyes when the
shoot those are real hits while it may
not have been the safest bet it
definitely worked he hit me i hit him
and they went all right now let's get
back to the movie and we did and nothing
but love this was actually the smaller
version of the major fight the plan was
actually to have a bigger battle if you
can imagine it but everything had to be
scaled back with their limited
production time the incredible fight
between stagecoach mary and trudy smith
is truly one of the highlights of the
movie but it didn't come easy the
actresses actually came back to the set
early just so they could rehearse this
fight even though netflix didn't want
them to the two of us and our stunt
doubles
rehearsed that for two days straight for
the two actors it was all about making
sure they could do justice and show off
just how incredible two women duking it
out on screen could be i wanted it to
look as
dangerous as possible it took seven days
for the crew to film the scene within
the train and it took a whole lot of
effort from everyone involved filming
this closed quarter scene was definitely
tricky since there was such a limited
space so everything was laid out in
storyboards beforehand just to make sure
they could capture everything they
wanted to effectively
they managed to using a steadicam and
another camera set up on a special
motorized slider that was hooked up to
the ceiling of the train the goal was
really just to do as many crazy things
as they could and that's you know a lot
of creative license because those guns
don't have shells that drop in my movie
they do from the script to the final
movie there were a number of changes on
the fly as the team went about filming
in a flexible way so they could
creatively collaborate together what was
in the original script and what we ended
on
uh is completely different whenever
there was a chance to build on a big
fight scene the team jumped on it and
built the biggest battle they could
dream of actually getting done
believe it or not there are real western
movie towns that just exist in new
mexico four of them were home to the set
of the harder they fall during shooting
but what we're introduced to on screen
isn't at all what these sets looked like
before a whopping
250 different shades were used to create
all these sets for douglas town the team
put a lot of focus into stagecoach
mary's bedroom since that's the only
intimate room of a character that we
actually see it might not be the
flashiest of towns but it's still a
stellar design redwood city might just
be the most stunning western town we've
ever seen with gorgeous jewel tones and
an impressive mayor's mansion which was
built from the ground up specifically
for this production
then of course there was maysville we
did do a couple of extensions and map
paintings while the whole city looks to
be an even tone there were actually
about 70 different shades of white paint
used to make everything look realistic
with contrast and depth what might be
most impressive is how they managed to
obtain the brilliant white dirt the
trick was ground up puma stones spread
over top of all the existing dirt
not every set includes appearances from
metal animal models but these figures
turned out to be the best solution to
help the actors practice an essential
cowboy skill
last sewing these practice animals may
not have been real but clearly they held
their own that wear and tear is rough
the good the bad and the ugly this team
filmed through it all shooting a movie
in the desert is tough this kind of
wicked sandstorm was a regular
occurrence when the production spent
some time filming near the border of new
mexico just over in colorado they got
snowed out off the bat these rough
filming conditions on top of including
so many complex stunts and horses meant
there was a lot of planning required and
perseverance but this whole crew was so
passionate about the film that they made
it work no matter what hurdles they
faced after all we shot that joint in
the middle of a pandemic the harder they
fall faced some tough challenges when
the pandemic hit and pretty early on in
their process
just five weeks in we were scheduled to
shoot and then idris came down with
coving we shut down elba just happened
to be one of the first major celebrities
to come down with the virus making
tensions extra high we went through a
trauma the first day before we started
filming i caught coving and this is at
the beginning
so the film halted for about eight
months unfortunately the actor didn't
really get to make the first impression
he'd hoped for with the cast and crew i
remember meeting everyone we were
greeting hugging kissing and then i had
to tell them hey man i have covered
while the team of the harder they fall
was well prepared and made sure all
their ducks were in a row none of them
could have prepared for what was coming
and we didn't have as much time as we
would have liked to the team was forced
to downsize a lot in terms of the scale
of the scenes as well as just the amount
of time they actually had for filming
but nevertheless they tried to fit in
everything they needed with their
limited time on set to make sure the
movie could be as good as they wanted it
to be and not over budget the fun part
was like bending genres and like
um you know creating with cuddy the
wicked soundtrack for this movie was
something special and considering jay-z
was one of the film's producers it's no
surprise since he was involved jay-z
also contributed to the songwriting and
produced the tracks loads of the pieces
included in the film were written
especially for the movie and brought it
to the next level the tunes are so
cleverly placed they even offer hints
throughout the movie what makes these
songs even better is the fact that some
of them are sung by the actual cast
members for the rest of the tracks vocal
talents came from the fisk jubilee
singers kid cudi lauren hill celo green
and seal having james samuel as the
movie's writer and director was a huge
bonus he was also responsible for
writing and producing tons of the songs
in the soundtrack making this film was a
huge feat even without the pandemic
delay but it was definitely worth the
wait for this feast for our eyes and
ears
which scene was your favorite